idris elba is the creeper fear the
creeper is actually called no good deed
as and no good deed goes unpunished but
I'm totally gonna call it the creeper
because he's a creeper so the creeper
stars Idris Elba and he says guys the
serial killer of women and now he's on
the run he goes to this chicks house is
pretty much him being a creep for a
movie I'd swear to god that's the
premise of the movie that's why it's the
creeper and a movie like this wouldn't
bother me you feel like maybe it'll have
that panic room type vibe and it
could've and it kind of does in scenes
but all in all it's just interest Elba
making the entire movie uncomfortable
which the movies supposed to be
uncomfortable and he's supposed to be
weird and creepy in that there's success
to that but really is there a point to
it that's the question first of all like
I just said it was Elba he's great in
the movie he's good it was apparent
early on and seeing this dude's work I
was like whatever this guy wants to
bring to the screen he brings to the
screen he brings it hard however he's so
good at being creepy he makes the people
in the movie stupid there's these guys
throwing up all the red flags he's
throwing out all the creepy vibe in the
world and he's going right through her
she's not seeing any of that which
is baffling to me since when she was
describing her job she was like I worked
on the Beast women cases and serial
psychos she might as well have just
turned to him in life I had the ideal
job just sniff you out when you're in my
house and she doesn't at all like the
only one who sniffs in mad is her
ass friend played by Leslie Bibb not
complaining Leslie Bibb is really hot
and I was fun in that really way
but she's straight up the one who's like
alright I have test-driven a lot of
dicks and there's something off about
that one and after that it's kind of a
home invasion movie but the guy's
already in the home so it's just a creep
movie it's Idris Elba's character making
this girl feel uncomfortable and
overpowering the out of her and
being belittling he's a narcissist Ted
Bundy type who has this girl in her
house and that's my problem with the
movie when I got out of the movie I was
like was there a point to the movie and
the answer is no because the movie
didn't have any wit to it yeah they do a
good job at making a Juris L but crave
it when it needs to be creepy and having
a really uncomfortable vibe in the room
but it kind of reminded me of the same
thing as those hostile movies those
torture porn movies this movie isn't
torture porn by any means there's not
really a lot of blood it's a different
thing but it's comparable in the sense
that those torture porn movies exist
just to have something happen in excess
so you walk out and go I saw that in
excess and that's why I went to say the
same thing here
this has creep factor in excess and
that's why the movie exists it exists
for no other reason other than that I
wasn't not entertained in the movie but
when I walked out I was like yeah time
well-spent
not really Idris Elba was really good in
it it did have a creepy vibe that's what
the movie was going for so it succeeded
in that what we're seeing this
narcissistic serial killer guy overpower
this girl for most of the movie she does
fight back so that's cool you feel like
the pitch for this movies like hey let's
have a movie where a guy is just a creep
and he's in the girls house huh
that's that nothing really was behind it
it didn't use its wits enough so I gotta
say the creeper you're not gonna
remember it in t minus a couple days yep
already forgot it first so who's your
favorite creepy guy in any movie
whatsoever
whoever he isshe is creeps can be chicks
whatever they are comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]